erste stunde in der grunewald
grundschule in berlin englisch für die
dritte klasse die lehrerin apps kann
gang sie ist eine so genannte
quereinsteigerin und noch in der
ausbildung alle paar monate sitzt ihrer
seminarleiterin im unterricht und
überprüft die fortschritte seit februar
steht die angehende lehrerin vor einer
klasse ohne pädagogische vorbildung für
die ehemalige übersetzerin nicht ganz
einfach schule und ausbildung
gleichzeitig es ist ganz schön viel das
stimmt es ist viel
die haben pro woche circa zehn stunden
seminar die unterrichte 19 stunden
zusätzlich dann muss man die den
unterricht geben vor nachbereiten
unterrichtsbesuche vorbereiten es ist
ganz schön viel
die 33 jährige unterrichtet außer geben
auch deutsch und mathe betreut wird sie
an der schule von einer gestandenen
lehrerin das nennen sie hier
professionalisierung konzept es ist
einzigartig in berlin
quereinsteiger unterrichten an ihrem
ersten arbeitstag selbstständig und zum
teil irgendeine betreuung und sie haben
vorher unter umständen kein praktikum
gemacht haben auch keine weiteren die
erfahrung
das heißt sie müssen unterstützung auch
aus dem kollegen bekommen
die quereinsteiger sollen lücken füllen
weil es in berlin genauso wie in allen
anderen bundesländern auch mehr kinder
gibt als vorausberechnet wesentlich viel
mehr kinder so dass in diesem jahr mehr
als die hälfte der in berlin neu
eingestellten grundschullehrer per
einsteiger sind und in der nächsten
jahren sollen jährlich 2.000 stellen neu
besetzt werden
wie kann es eigentlich sein dass nicht
genügend lehrer ausgebildet wurden frage
ich die pressesprecherin der
senatsverwaltung für bildung jugend und
familie
vor zehn jahren hätte man anders an den
universitäten schon den hebel umlegen
müssen um jetzt die lehrkräfte
tatsächlich auch an den schulen zu haben
wo musik passiert
das müssen sie die damaligen
verantwortlichen fragen da kann man
natürlich sagen wir haben das damals
noch nicht gesehen was sie auf uns
zukommt an bevölkerungswachstum und
dieses wachstum hat auch ihr die
eigentlich musik studiert hatte den job
gebracht sabine pendelt kommt nach einem
zwölf stunden tag von der arbeit nach
hause wirklich in jeden tag mehr weil
ich jetzt nach drei jahren auch das
gefühl hat es läuft im gegensatz zu
jemand der lehramt studiert hat wurde
die quereinsteigerin gleich an ihrem
ersten arbeitstag ins kalte wasser
gestoßen
der klassenlehrer ist immer dabei der
klassenlehrer gibt mir feedback die
klassenlehrerin meistens an der
grundschule und ich bekomme jeder zeit
die unterstützung die ich brauche oder
ob ich alleine vor einer dritten vierten
fünften sechsten klasse stehe und das
heißt bitte mathe unterrichten
sie können doch rechnen und das ist
wirklich absurd es ist wirklich ich
hab's absolut komplett absurd gefunden
quereinsteiger sind kein berliner
problem bundesweit werden über 20.000
lehrer gesucht auch at wie stark muss
nur eine 18-monatige ausbildung hinter
sich bringen
dann bekommt sie wahrscheinlich eine
unbefristete festanstellung und wird wie
eine normale grundschullehrerin mit
einem monatseinkommen von über 5000 euro
bezahlt ohne solche quereinsteiger ist
der schulbetrieb in deutschland nicht
mehr zu stemmen